welcome everybody
this afternoon lectures we will be
talking we will be looking at
newer topics and
it's a pleasure to introduce david
steiner with cornell university
visiting for the whole semester so he'll
be here for the whole semester and
he'll be talking with television summer
squares sdp relaxations
and their applications to approximation
algorithms
or even uh
okay so the the
motivation so i want to start with some
motivation so
so we'll be trying to solve optimization
problems
and um like most of the discussion is
very general and i'll
have some examples and so the kind of
optimization problem that we're
interested in are
following form so we have some function
that we want to maximize
and we have some properties that we want
um
of the solutions
followed by by these kind of equations
and the solution
is encoded as a real vector
and here we are thinking of
of n as very large so we have many
variables
and in the sense that we will also
measure
yes larger we will measure
the running time
of the algorithms in terms of the number
of variables
again if you sort of talk about real
value you know a function on
real vectors and we have to somehow say
how we how we encode these functions and
the way we will do this
is that the functions
are you know low degree polynomials
it could be degree two or degree four
so really just just a constant degree
and
it also
you know the the number of constraints
will be small
and no coefficients will be small
that's the the um the basic setup and um
an example of a problem that um and this
is a very
um expressive
expressive way of describing
optimization problems an example
of a problem how you can describe a
problem in this way
is let's say for the maximum cut in a
graph
a little bit larger
graph g with the you know n vertices
okay so so how could we so we want to
find it by partition
we want to find it by partition of of of
the vertex set of the graph
such that the number of edges that cross
the bipartition is as large as possible
so how can we how can we encode it in
this way
so the main the main step is
to sort of encode the
solutions
real vectors and
there's a equivalent ways of doing it uh
maybe the simple thing is that we um
we think of we have a variable for every
vertex
i we have a variable x sub i and
a coordinate of a vector and we assign
you know one to all the vertices on one
side of the cut
and minus one to all the vertices
on the other side of the cut and then
you know we want to um formulate you
know that
we want to express the condition that we
want to
maximize the number of edges that are
that the repetition cuts
in terms of some function p0
so you know p0 of x should be the
number of edges that cross
the by partition x
and you know this function um you you
know you can
interpolate as a binomial in these
variables
and then it has this form
so so here we sum up over the edges of
the graph
these these squares and you see that
they just count the number of edges that
cross the repetition
and so this is this laplacian of the
graph
which you've seen in the lucas torque
okay and so so we're lucky the you know
the this point normally is indeed a lot
of degree points
so this uh this fits into um
into what we uh what what what we said
before you also say that
um yes
so uh yes i think that's what i actually
think
right so so what we what we did here is
we every bipartition we associated with
some vector
some vector x with plus one minus one
coordinates
and now we want um if i want
you know we have this if you specify the
constraints here
and so the way we choose um p1 uh up to
pm
the way we want to system forming
moments is you choose this as
a good basis
of polynomials
that that are zero over
over the set that we're interested in
and good basis i can mean uh
different things depending on exactly
what problem you're looking at
uh here it's sort of a clear what's
what's the
what what's the basis that you want um
so you you know you choose the following
uh point it's just uh x 1 squared minus
1
up to x n squared minus 1.
so so the condition that those
polynomials are 0
says that the vector x has plus or minus
and okay so this is the basic um
the basic setup now the question that
we're interested in is you know
are there efficient algorithms for these
kind of problems
and um yes you probably know this this
problem is uh
and be hard let's say um
even talk um it's it's it's a uh
it's it's keeping this example of mexico
so the efficient algorithm so this
problem isn't hard to solve exactly
and uh even in the sense that so the
proof
uh the hardness proof even shows that
you know if you want to solve it exactly
it requires
under some reasonable assumptions uh
exponential time
and now so that means that the real
question is that you know
how close can you get um
and um there's a you know basic results
this p theorem says that um you know
sort of some kind of 0.99 approximation
is as hard as
in solving the problem exactly
okay here i should also say um the you
know
maybe uh i'm not sure if you remember
from lucas or
we measure approximation so so usually
you have to um
you might have to measure it depending
on the problem but
in this case you know
some alpha approximation means that
means that the the solution uh
found by the algorithm on on a
particular input
graph g is you know at least alpha times
uh the optimum value of the optimum
resolution for the graph
and this is for all for all clouds
so here i am
so this this is a the hardness result so
this is a you know this is an even
0.9 approximation requires exponential
time
and right and then there's this
and they are better ones known but you
know
for heartless results but let me not say
them and then there is this you know the
best
algorithm like it's an eight
approximation
and um
you know assuming any games conjecture
you know implies that np-hard
no better approximation is empty here
and um okay then we you know we don't
know if the
negan's conjecture is true and in some
sense that's um
you know finding out whether the game is
actually true is one of the motivations
of
the things that i'm talking about now um
you might you might wonder okay why do
we really care about you know the
difference between
point nine nine point eight and eight so
i think uh you know
maybe um one reason why you want to care
about this is that
here you know you're maybe not
interested just in the numerical value
but you want to know you know what's
what's the algorithm that that achieves
the best possible approximation
and if you look at this then
here the algorithm that achieves 0.878
um this is based on
on let me call it degree 2 7 programming
again this is sort of not a very
technical expression
quotes um and
now there's something interesting
happens for example it's open
what is you know just like there's
degree two or seven different
programming
there are uh know it's open but the
they are you know higher degree uh uh
versions of simulation programming and
so you can look at degree four uh
simulation programming
and this is uh you know it's open
whether this gives a better a strictly
better approximation
you know and if if if it would be the
case
that that would refute um
this the suny games conjecture
in some sense our inability to to show
that
you know this version of simultaneously
programming does not
refute against conjecture explains why
we are not super confident in in
in the truth of the negan's conjecture
and it's even a bit worse
so it's not just open that whether this
you know degree 4 achieves a better
approximation but
okay so you can speak
with a little bit more
okay so every known uh it's against some
religion
type in a bad example for
for degree 2.
this is it's provably
not a bad example
for degree 16
here and the 16 is sort of some somewhat
arbitrary number
okay so and uh and here you know every
known uh so the restriction is
you know known to me
but uh so this means that you know
every particular construction of of
graphs
where uh you know where we know that or
you know
that where the degree two
whenever the degree this guarantee for
degree two is tight
uh you can actually show that degree 16
is much better
okay and this is um maybe somewhat
uh surprising especially uh
so that means that uh you know using
game conjecture is true
then you know degree 16 should not give
a better approximation for this problem
and so it means that they have to be
different uh instances uh the degree of
the degree of polynomials over here
um yes i have a good question
so here um so there are two degrees
uh play one is the degree of
that you need to specify the problem and
for mexico this is degree two
and to some extent you can you know
degree two is always enough to is
to to to define at least sort of
combinatorial kind of problems
and uh and then there is uh the degree
that you use for the for the algorithm
and those degrees are
you can you can choose a degree for the
algorithm larger
and and that's the and that's that that
turns out
to help for these bad instances but yeah
so so far i didn't explain exactly what
the 316
um cemetery programming means and
everybody
to do that okay and so
so the conclusion of this kind of
discussion is that
you know the goal here is what we
like to have is uh some kind of um
unified so we have you know so this is
really just some kind of uh
some particular example this mexico and
so you know
a lot of problems uh uh
you know of different kinds where every
you know that have this form this kind
of optimization problems and
we would like to understand what are the
best uh best possible algorithms
and so the goal is to have some kind of
you know
unified way of
of attacking these problems
approaching these problems
and you know in the sense that you know
this
should apply to other combinatorial
optimization problems
and another kind of other kind of
problems where these kind of techniques
seem to be useful
are certain unsupervised learning
problems
like you know
relative sparsity
tensors
and the matrix factorization kind of
things
and
this this unified way of approaching
these problems is in terms of
convex relaxations
and this is that's the main topic of
the lecture today um so we so
so the basic idea is that okay we have
these we have these problems and we
uh we try to um and that's the sense
that uh convex optimization is easy and
so the the idea is to
to reduce um uh these arbitrary
optimization
problems to convex optimization problems
and then hope that in this way we get a
good good algorithms
and uh okay so so there are
uh there are different ways of doing
this and so what i will explain is sort
of some some kind of
way of looking at uh at these kind of
expectations that that
is very unified and
so the first one thing that we need to
do
is we need to condensify
other problem
and so it means that you know we want to
you want to make the you know you want
to make a problem into a convex problem
without extraordinary incident
you know you can take um from these
combinations of solutions and get
solutions that are uh
at least as good so if you have a bunch
of good complete solutions and you take
it from the examination
and you want to have another good
solution
and like
and there's a canonical way to make
every problem context
so what's this what's how
how can you do this
so instead of just trying to find a
particular solution
what you try to do is you try to find a
distribution over solutions
and
you know these
what do we want to do
okay so let me let me let me keep this
example of max cut
just will make things a little bit
easier
so that's how how do you convexify
mexico and here if you want to
you want to find a distribution d
this probability distribution
over the hypercube
and you want to maximize the expectation
of
of of the polynomial that you're
interested in
or with respect to this distribution
okay and so so what did we gain
uh we get a couple of things so maybe
uh maybe let me just explain what is the
distribution
so distribution is a you know function
on the hypercube
the real valued function and it has a
property that for every you know point
in the hypercube
it takes a more negative value and if
you sum up the values
of all points in the hypercube then you
get one
and okay so that's the distribution but
what we gain
so one thing is that we get into that
here now this
this objective function is linear indeed
another thing that we gained is that now
that now the problem is convex in the
sense that
you know if you take two uh two
distributions of that if you obtain d
prime
and you uh take a convex combination in
the sense
think of it as a function then uh you
know this is again uh
i know it's a distribution
d and d prime are distributions
okay and so um
the only problem here is um so maybe
there are two problems one one problem
is okay so this object here is
exponentially large
this is actually not not not the main
problem
the main problem here is that
we have here an exponential number of
inequalities
and these inequalities are sort of not
not structured in a way that would um
uh would allow to you know to deal with
them in an efficient way
and so so that's the that's the main
problem and
let me also say that
instead of
instead of so finding a distribution and
maximizing the expectation
over the of the point that you want to
of the function you want to maximize
it's um something's a bit better
okay where should i write this um let me
write this down here
it's a bit better to in some situations
to think of
do you want to find a distribution
over the set
you know of all optimal solutions
you know where c is some guess for the
optimal
for the optimal value
okay so so meaning that um
instead of finding um so by
connectifying uh
i mean that we mean that instead of
finding a particular solution what you
try to do is you find
distribution over solutions okay and i
priority this doesn't make
you know things easier so you know in
particular you know this problem is
computationally at least it's hard but
it but what you gain is that it gives
you a new perspective on the problem and
so in particular now we we will relax
the problem we make the problem easier
and the
so some of you want to you know want to
keep the property that things are convex
because then we can use
convex optimization techniques but um
but we somehow want to um
uh i want to simplify the problem so
that we can
you know we can solve things efficiently
and you know
there are many ways of um of sort of
explaining uh
how this how this goes but i think um
uh you know particular you know a
very general way and you know convenient
way to
to deal with these things is in terms of
pseudo distributions
okay so so what is uh zero distribution
so short way to think about it is that
it behaves
like a probability solution
distribution over
let's say optimal solutions
so it means you know in terms of in the
case of max cut over optimal
cuts in the graph and it
you know it behaves as this kind of
object
with respect
to
our computational knowledge
about um optimal solutions
so this computational knowledge is
something that i will define
in a bit
so there's a sense in which um you know
you can think about what do you know
what do you actually know about
optimal solutions and then you you can
you can think about what it means to
have a
something like a distribution that it's
something that
behaves like a distribution with respect
to this knowledge
okay um
and then so once we have this the
general approach will be
find the zero distribution efficiently
and then extract
you know a good solution you know it
might not be an optimal solution but
but the goal is to you know still be
able to get a good solution
from this serial distribution
you know there will be some loss here
which is which will determine the
approximation factor
okay so this is the the the general idea
and
okay here you know there are different
ways of thinking about this
step um you know this sometimes called
rounding
other ways related it's also related to
polymorphisms
and we're calling it sometimes combining
and uh yeah it will be clearer later in
later lectures what
you know how to think about this process
um okay so now what
um what is this computational knowledge
this one
yes because you know we don't want them
to be um you know exactly probability
solutions but only with respect to what
we know about the problem
so that means that you know
it's easier that it's easier to find
these kind of objects than uh
than actual problem distributions and
the the algorithms that
uh that will find these two
distributions they are
um you know comic optimization
problems so it turns out that this will
be um finding a zero distribution will
be a convex optimization problem
you know which is not surprising because
you know finding actual distributions is
also convex optimization problem
but uh but here this will be a small
convex of presentation
so now okay so what is uh what is
computational knowledge
so let's first start with okay what is
knowledge about optimal solutions so
it's just um
a set of functions it has a property
that
you know if f if if s f is a function in
in the set
it implies that f x
is non-negative for every
optimal solution
for every solution
x of value c where c
was our guess for for the optimal value
and this is sort of something that you
can always make you know if you can
guess what's the optimal value and then
just try to find
uh try to see if you can find a
distribution
for that particular value c okay
now um
this is so this is just a you know just
a
you know a bunch of inequalities that
you know about um
about optimal solutions okay and
now what does it mean to have a serial
distribution that is consistent
d is consistent with some particular
knowledge okay
so this just so this is just um
uh just means that um you know for every
function that we know to be non-negative
or
you know that we know to be non-negative
over uh on
on optimal solutions you want that
the following expression is
negative okay maybe let me uh
okay the following expression is uh
negative
sum of all points in either cube um
the some kind of inner product between
the function d
and the function f and another the other
condition is that
if you sum up the values
of of d then then you get one so it
means that
we replace the condition that there is
no negative everywhere
by the condition that by this
strange condition okay so and
and it sort of gets gets old to write
these sums
and therefore we will give this a name
and annotation
so we'll denote it in this way
so this is the sorry clearer here
so this summation for any function f
we denote it in this way and we will
refer to it as the pseudo expectation
of f yes will there be examples where
the knowledge uses the
optimal value c um
that's a good question
maybe not uh today but uh
so there are some cases where uh
where things become much more pleasant
if you uh
if you know if you use the
value c so see the expectation
from an expectation because they could
be positive yes exactly
so that's yeah so that's what we what we
dropped so we you know no longer
require that these negative errors um
you know we uh we trust but we keep the
condition that uh b subs
sums up to one and uh instead of when
there can be
no negativity everywhere we just require
that these two expectations
are not negative for functions that we
know to be non-negative
on optimal solutions okay and
now um okay
yes so in like a lot of the examples
f your zero degree yes
so somehow uh
like clearly not you know
so we have to resp so the question is um
you know when can we argue about
consistency with respect to some
particular
set of functions k when can we deal with
this
efficiently and and
you know we can't do it every you know
for some for some set of functions
it's not possible to do it efficiently
so for example if k consists of
another example so if you choose
our knowledge to be you know all
the set of
singleton indicators
now for every point x we have a function
in k
which is one exactly at this point x and
zero everywhere else
so because we can look at this this or
let's say um it is just one at every
um for every point for every solution x
it has value c
um so if you know if you had um
the indicator of every such solution in
our set k then um
you know it means then then it means
that um
yes then you know
you know distribution with vector that's
okay
is an actual distribution
you know it's an actual distribution
that means that we somehow have to
restrict the set of functions a
and that's um
what it means that we you know
if we only get a zero distribution that
is consistent with our respect to our
computational knowledge
and so this means that there exists
so there's some parameter d so there
exists an enter the d time algorithm
that can solve the you know the
following problem uh
you know given f given a function d
sorry
you compute the
the function our you know knowledge that
minimizes you know the smallest zero
expectation
so for every for every function d you
want to be able to
compute
sorry given d
you want to compute
you know the function in k that
minimizes
this expectation a different way of
thinking about it is that given some
function d
you want to be able to tell whether um
you know whether whether it's consistent
uh with with the knowledge k in the
sense that
you know that all these zero
explanations are none right no negative
and if if d is not consistent with uh
with
the knowledge k then you want to be and
you want to find some function f
that is um whether the
expectation is negative
second that's the definition of
computational knowledge
right so so there exists a uh
anti-detail algorithm
that can solve the following problem you
know given a function d
compute the function f that minimizes
this uh
this expectation so for every value of
little d you have a different set of
computational knowledge
um yes yes i mean
yes i think maybe i should have uh yes
good
i'm saying no right so so here
um you know you know a priority uh you
know it's a function on on
two to the end points so that you know
it's much larger than the time the
algorithm has
so you somehow have to you know have to
represent
the in a good way
and here um the
let's go back to my newest point we will
um
we will assume that we only look at
the case where this set k
contains only degree d points
you know wherever this d here is roughly
the same as this this g
uh contains only degree in equal numbers
and what so what does it make why does
this make
things easier
this makes things easier because so now
now the set the set of functions that we
care about that we know
we know to be non-negative they are all
degree d polynomials
and so it means that in this expression
the like the higher degree part of d
so you know every every function capital
b you can
write it as a node degree part plus a
high degree function
and the high degree part it will not be
able to contribute in this
in this expression because um because f
is a lonely green point
so the high degree part doesn't
contribute here and
so it means that we can represent
d by its low degree part
if if
if you said if our knowledge only
contains
lowly frequencies
so that means you're looking at the
moments up to the
moment yes that's right okay
so so that means that the only thing
that we know about
um or the the only thing that matters uh
of this um of this function capital d
is it's low degree moments but in some
sense they are not actual moments
because you know this function might
take
might take negative values sometimes and
so um
yes i guess you could call these numbers
pseudomoments
i guess are there so are you saying that
we don't know of applications where
a height or high degree functions f are
needed but
that was not withstanding are there uh
interesting classes of
hierarchy as for which we know how to
solve
this um basically separation problem ah
okay yes that's a good question
um
okay so so far i i didn't specify um
exactly what uh so that's what comes
next
so next we will discuss complete
examples of what
you know what could be how would the set
k look like um
and so one one case is that you just
just let k be uh
you know some kind of cone generated by
a small number of rays
by a polynomial number of rays and then
you can always um
then it's always possible to to solve
this problem efficiently
and um i mean yeah so so there's the
sense in which you can
um which you don't need to not
don't need low degree uh polynomials if
you want things to be efficient
but we don't know of an example where
that's actually useful
that's also a great open question to
show that uh glorified things are the
best
this is the only thing so you did this
in some generality but then
at some point it didn't make sense to
anymore to say to talk about things that
were not all degrees because you need
some
implicit representation for d but you
say
but you're saying if if k is in some
sense finite dimensional then you also
have a finite mesh representation for d
uh yes sorry boundaries dimensional yes
yes so the yes that's right so if um
okay i think um
that's probably uh some kind of
necessary condition that uh
that that if you look at the affine span
of the the linear span of k that this
should
uh not be too large um otherwise uh
there's not no hope
otherwise it cannot be computationally
efficient in
this sense okay and
yes maybe let me state the theorem
which is in some sense just uh resetting
the fact that
convicts you know punish problems you
can solve them efficiently
um you know if you have uh this
you know uh
you know that um
you know to find a zero distribution be
consistent with
computation you know if you have some
computational knowledge
alrighty and this is really just um
um the observation that
um if you can use this um
this problem that you have to solve here
is sort of the separation problem for
the this you know it's a separation
problem
for these zero distributions and um
and therefore you know using uh you know
the ellipsoid method or your other
favorite
convex optimization uh algorithm you can
you can find
uh a serial distribution that is
efficiently that is
consistent with the uh complicated
angular
some computational knowledge so yeah you
can either think of this as
a separation oracle or also some kind of
algorithm that computes the sub gradient
of
of the function that you want to
minimize or sometimes okay so now
um there are not
examples
so one uh one example is that you can
use some kind of local
knowledge
and this would be this will correspond
to
choosing k to be all the non-negative
combinations
of non-negative
defenders okay so this this kind of i
mean
these are decontaus over the hypercube
is a function that depends only on
what was the variables
so these are you know functions that um
you know there are negative everywhere
on the hypercube so in particular they
satisfy this here
um and um
you know if you choose d to be uh if you
just need to be very large like
n then uh you you will also have these
uh
you know the set will also contain these
indicators that means that you choose d
to the n then you actually you know talk
about
actual probability distributions and uh
but another fact is that so the number
of rays here
so this is a convex cone and the number
of rays
is you know roughly two to the
uh times the entropy
and so it means that um you know in this
case you can just solve this problem by
you know trying out every every ray here
uh and that you know it takes time
roughly and just into the d
yeah and and this year uh use this kind
of uh
local knowledge that that is the
resulting um
algorithm is called the cheryl adams
np relaxation
now another kind of knowledge that you
can use is
some squares knowledge
and here that would be
all polynomials that are sums you know
alcohols that are sum of squares
of 3d polynomials
okay so these are you know also not
negative so you know
it means that uh you know you can do
this also if you don't choose degree
to just b to be very large then
you know you you get these indicators
which which means that you
solve the problem exactly now why is it
computationally
efficient so case if we have to look at
this
this kind of problem
and basically
so this problem becomes you know given
some low degree polynomial d so these
now
as we said here are not equally
polynomial you want to find
the you know the
arcman of um
you know
you know we are interested in squares of
low degree point moments so we go over
every low degree
polynomial p and we want to minimize uh
the pseudo expectation we don't find a
point on repeat where this
this pseudo expectation is as small as
possible
and now if you look at this here
this is a quadratic form in
form in p and so it means that you know
minimizing that is a
is a just some eigenvalue kind of
problem because that's something that
you can do efficiently
this is your separation line yes that
would be a separation
so the separation oracle for for sum of
squares knowledge would be an eigenvalue
computation
might be almost at this time
so the point that i'd like to make here
is that
the sum of squares knowledge is
surprisingly
close to our real world knowledge about
loading people in augments so you know
if you give me sort of a concrete
uh no degree polynomial inequality then
you know it's very likely that at least
in an approximate sense
it's captured by by the sum of squares
knowledge
and that means that um
and that sort of means that in some
sense if you if you work with these
uh if you work with a serial
distribution that is consistent with
this kind of sum of space knowledge
and you sort of you know you're thinking
about
algorithms that you know try to extract
uh
you know a good solution from a serial
distribution it's very hard for them to
notice a difference between uh having
just a serial distribution and having an
actual distribution
just because um you know our
real world knowledge about the low
degree polynomials is very
very very very captured by uh by this
kind of sum of space knowledge
and so this informs the following
some kind of algorithm design approach
you know an approach for for
for solving this problem for extracting
a good solution
so you know what um analyze
this rounding step
and while pretending
or you know pretending that we have an
actual distribution
let's say low degree moments
actual distribution
and then only afterwards
you know check that
that only some squares knowledge
no degrees on the squares knowledge
was used about the solutions
okay and this is the advantage that
some of these this verification is uh
can be uh
technically involved and
dealing with dealing with it separately
makes things
much cleaner
alright this is easier
okay
they have say five more minutes uh yes
sure sure so i just wanted to
sketch
it's just a technique
how you
how you can use these distributions to
create to design algorithms
it's not uh it's you know
the example is chosen so that it's most
it's familiar
but you could i mean for this particular
example you could also do it in a
different way which might be simpler and
depending on which is
um and this will be uh
you know suppose we try to um
approximation for max
try to get an approximation for mexico
using two distributions
okay so so uh suppose
that we have a graph g
and it has a you know bipartition
did the one minus epsilon
objection of etcher's
crossing so one nice absolute fraction
of the edges of the graph across this by
partition
and our goal is to find
you know find a partition
with the one minus or the root epsilon
of the edges crossing
here's the other
because we will compute
zero distribution
that is you know consistent with
let's say degree 2 with some squares
knowledge
and you know the condition that the
laplacian
is equal to 1 minus epsilon times the
number of edges in the graph
that just means that this fraction of
edges cross
okay now we want to um you know extract
from the
distribution uh an actual distribution
an actual solution solution
and the way this we can do this is um
so i will explain why these steps work
random variable
let's call it y
that has the same
degree two moments
as the suitable distribution d
okay and um
and then we will just output
maybe it'll be just a bit uh
differently so if if this this
distribution would be an actual
distribution what we'd like to do is
just sample from this distribution okay
but
but as we said before we only know the
low degree moments of this distribution
and if you have
you know this in general you know it's
hard to um
to sample from a distribution that has
the same uh
test the same uh you know even the
moments it's hard for example
from distribution has the same moments
uh one thing that we can do is we can
sample a real valued random variable
that has the same
degree two moments okay and so all of
these words are important
so it's a real valid random variable and
to test the same
degree two moments that's something that
we can do or and that will explain why
and then we'll output
the closest point output the pointer z
which is important device we take the
sine
of of the render variable y and
this is our by partition okay so this is
the closest
but you know closest point on the
barbecue
to the vector y
and
so what i uh
and and then okay so there's one claim
which which will establish that you uh
you know that that
you get this kind of guaranteed is that
um
you know if the probability
under the serial distribution that you
know x i is different from x j
is equal to 1 minus epsilon
then the probability which is now with
respect to the actual distribution
of z you all the z r differs from dj
this will be at least one minus order
root
okay
now
now what's what's sort of one one step
that is uh that
is not so clear at this point maybe why
can we sample um a real
value random variable that has the same
degree two moments as
this is similar definition t and so
so what we'll do is we will you know
we'll sample a gaussian variable that
has uh
that we look at we will compute the
degree to let's say the covariance of b
okay so how does what does the
covariance mean
we look at the following matrix
and with this notation here it's just um
you know it means exactly the same as uh
as here so we you know we use
d to wait to weigh to weigh these
matrices
we get a new matrix and we claim that
this is uh
so this will be we will try to choose we
will start with a gaussian it has this
covariance matrix
and but but for this if i mean in order
to put for
in order in order for this to be you
know if you want to be able to do this
then
this matrix needs to be uh positively
seminar
okay so this is the this is the main
question why should this matrix be
positive
if similarly if this matrix is positive
seven if semi-definite then you can
choose uh just a you know gaussian
matrix with this covariance metric
this is for variance i'm sorry mu here
is the mean of the series solution
so why is this uh uh matrix uh
for 67 so if this would be an actual
distribution then
it would just be a you know a
non-negative weighing of of these
matrices
of these psd matrices so it would be
obvious and clearly psp
but you know we have to
because it's a serial distribution you
have to you know you should verify it
and so now let's look at any vector u
and look at um
you know whether the quadratic form if
you plug in u is not negative
and all this this this this pseudo
expectation behaves exactly like you
would expect
from a from
from your actual expectation using you
know this definition
and so this is the same as the
value of this credit form is the same as
the expectation of this
square
okay so this identity would be true if
this would be an actual distribution
and actually expectation but you know
because we're just using linearity this
is also true for the pseudo expectations
and now you know we see that this here
is a square of a linear polynomial
linear polynomial in x
and that means that it's in uh you know
that this year is
you know contained in our uh you know
in our sum of squares you know degree 2
is our squares knowledge
so it means that this is not negative
for every u
and that means that the matrix is
positive
okay thanks so uh let me just say uh
so in the next lecture i wanted to talk
about
limitations of these kind of
algorithms and how we can use them to
solve some unique games in some service
financial time
and on friday i wanted to talk about
applications of this to findings past
vectors in subspaces
and density compositions thank
since it's you probably you take your
questions offline